NAZMUL IDRIS: Welcome
to this episode of UXD,
where we'll highlight
one of three
commonly missed opportunities
for applications
to deliver delight
to their users.
This is the third and
last part of the 3 Steps
to Awesome series.
I'm your host, Nazmul
Idris a developer
advocate passionate
about design and mobile.
And I have, with me,
a very special guest.
PATRICK LARVIE: Thanks, Nazmul.
I'm Patrick Larvie, I'm a UX
researcher here at Google.
I've been working
on mobile for years.
And I have lots to say.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Awesome.
So make sure to create
applications that are actually
useful and add value
to people's lives.
So before thinking about
the best interaction
design, or the best visual
design for your application,
or even the best engineering,
or the best feature set,
it's really important to, first,
validate your assumptions about
whether users actually need
your app in the first place.
It's kind of crazy.
But you really have to value
that assumption first and set
the goals correctly.
So build applications that
people actually want to use.
And then delight them with
an amazing user experience.
PATRICK LARVIE: Getting
the details of that right
is going to different series.
But I think we can start
here with some real basics
that you can use to make
sure that this is true.
And the first thing to
remember is usability really
is job one for every
app developer out there.
Some of these things are
going to sound super basic
and you're going
to say, well these
are the things already do.
But just check.
Just make sure that you're
thinking about this.
The first thing I
want to think about
is, what are the
physical constraints
and what the physical
possibilities of the form
factor I'm designing for.
Tablet.
Phone.
What is it that
you're designing for?
These are not similar.
They are both
different from laptops.
They're both devices that live
with app based ecosystems.
That doesn't mean
that they're the same.
Think about some of the very
first tablet-like devices
they came out.
The Kindle, these are
optimized for reading.
They look very much like books.
And, in fact, we
know this is why
people are buying these tablets.
They enjoy reading books.
They enjoy reading magazines.
They enjoy reading
all kinds of content.
That's not necessarily
true for mobile phones.
You can read a novel
on a smartphone.
You're not going to
be reading that novel
on your mobile phone.
And this is just-- this is
one of the subtle, but really,
really important
differences that you
need to understand
about form factor.
Think, not just about
how users interact
with what they see on a screen.
But you can also think about how
information gets to the device
and comes back
out of the device.
Text-to-speech and
voice input are really
important to think about.
They're really novel
ways of interacting
with a mobile phone.
If you're not familiar with
it, familiarize yourself
with Google Now.
It has some awesome examples of
how-- what the mobile device--
a kind of device
people are often
using while they're doing
other kinds of things.
You can say, how long how
long is a Golden Gate Bridge,
as you're, perhaps
peddling across it.
And it will speak
back to you and say,
it is-- I'm not sure, a mile
and a half, or whatever it is.
So this is a novel, but
entirely appropriate,
way of using text to
speech and voice input
on a device like that.
May not be the best
thing to use on a tablet.
It depends a lot
on the situation.
But the form factor between
these two kinds of devices
has vast implications
that often people
are not thinking through.
Do not attempt to just reuse
smartphone applications
for tablets.
It's a fundamental mistake.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Yeah, exactly.
I think, to your point
if the difference
in usage between smart
phones and tablets
on the go on mobile
devices, like smart phones,
people have really,
really limited attention
to devote to these
particular devices.
Because they're also taking in
their environment and so on.
So it's not appropriate
to make big, big demands
of their attention
while they're on the go
and using their application.
Whereas in a tablet,
maybe you're at home.
The context is very different.
And so you can then
optimize things
more for content consumption,
rather than content creation,
or even things that
you need to do,
tasks you need to execute o.
PATRICK LARVIE: That's right.
You know, that's a
really good point.
There are lots of studies
that show that the smartest,
most switched-on user who really
wants to interact throughout
has a more limited attention
span, and more limited--
has just basically
less memory to use
when using a mobile
phone than when
using other kinds of devices.
Keep this in mind.
It's not that the
user is different.
It's that the device
imposes this difference.
When you've got a
mobile phone, you're
also attending to
the environment.
You're tending to lots
of different things.
This reduces the
amount of attention.
amount of brain power
a person can bring to
whatever app they're using.
So this is really
important to think about,
because I know a lot of you have
heard, or are thinking about,
or are currently using
responsive design.
And responsive design is a
fantastic engineering fix.
But I do not think of
it as a design solution,
because it is not.
Just because you
can take that novel
and put on a mobile phone,
doesn't mean you should.
Do not just reflow web pages
on a mobile because you
can use responsive design.
Think-- going back that
novel, think about it.
On a mobile phone, with a
person's reduced ability
to attend, a person's reduced
attention span, a person's
reduced memory, the
table of contents
is going to work really well.
Something where you're going to
select between several options.
And you go to some
other kind of content.
The novel, the
inside of a chapter,
completely inappropriate.
So just because you can put
lots of text on a phone,
does not mean you
have-- responsive design
does not, in any way, optimize
text for mobile devices.
It simply puts that
text on mobile devices.
That is the beginning
of your job.
It's not the end.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Exactly.
PATRICK LARVIE: You
know, I think one thing--
this is-- I wanted to talk a
little bit about cowboy design.
Lots of people like to
leave their signature.
Lots of people like to have
a strong brand presence.
It is a wild, wild west
out there without design.
Lots of you know this.
You've had lots of
apps that you look
and you say, wow, I have
absolutely no idea what
this is, or what it does.
This is not a way of making
your user feel welcome,
because your user is not
going to feel in control.
They're not going
to feel like they
understand what's going on.
If you-- the reason for
platform conventions
isn't just to straight
jacket everybody
into a series of design patterns
that otherwise make no sense.
The point is to make
everybody feel comfortable,
everybody feel in charge
with what their doing.
Internal-- learn and internalize
those design guidelines.
You sometimes have
to deviate, as we've
said in the other episodes.
Sometimes you have to deviate.
You should do so purposefully
and thoughtfully.
If you're not sure
how to approach this,
find a coder buddy, and
go through the guidelines
until you thoroughly
understand them.
Remember that users
expect objects
to behave in a certain way.
And there's absolutely no
reason to confuse or befuddle
your user.
And when you're
going to deviate,
do so, but do so in a very
thoughtful and purposeful way.
The other thing about-- that
I just want to say about apps
is that you want to
know about location.
And generally, when app
designers think about location,
they think GPS.
I want you to think
about internal location.
Does the user know where he
or she is within your app?
Am I on my homepage?
Am I on my content page?
Where am I?
Where can I go from here?
Where can I go next?
And what will I do there?
This is actually a
fundamental heuristic.
And you can and
should be applying
it to walk through your app
before it gets released.
NAZMUL IDRIS: That makes sense.
PATRICK LARVIE: And
I know a lot of you
out there already know this.
This is super, super basic.
But it's surprising
how many people
fail to attend to this
fundamental, super basic aspect
of design.
Please be sensitive to the
48 DPI minimum touch target
size when building anything
on a mobile device.
And by the way,
that 48 DPI, that's
for the actual touch target.
You need a buffer zone
around that touch target
as well because you can't see
it out there in video land,
but my fingers are kind of big.
And if you don't have an
appropriate buffer around them,
or you need a zone
around those tap
targets to keep your
user from inadvertently
touching the wrong thing.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Exactly.
So I think along these
lines of touch targets,
Prototyping on Paper is a really
good application for Android
and iPhone that I
encourage you guys use.
You could basically
take pictures
with your camera off
actual screen shots,
or basically wire
frames, or anything
that you're drawing on paper.
You, essentially, just
take pictures of them,
and then wire them
together, and then
create a flow that
allows you to interact
with different parts of
those scanned images.
So it's a really,
really good way
to test out your
design, to make sure
that you've gotten some of
these touch targets right
before you actually do the
expensive part of actually
protecting it and developing it.
So I hope you got
your episode today.
Just remember, by
following our three steps,
you too can avoid
common pitfalls
and make awesome applications.
Also, if you haven't already,
please join our UX community
on Google Plus, we
curate information
about all things
that are related UX.
PATRICK LARVIE:
What's it called?
What's the community called?
NAZMUL IDRIS: It's called
UX Design for Developers.
And the QR code is
actually on the screen,
along with a link for it.
So thank you, Patrick,
for being on the show.
PATRICK LARVIE: Thank you,
Nazmul, for having me.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Thanks for
watching, join us next time,
and goodbye.